here's what would happen if a spider  entered your body if a spider were to  fall into your extremely acidic stomach  it would be no match for that powerful  gut of yours however things could get  bad if a venomous spider were to latch  onto your esophagus and bite you on the  way down then you'd need up to 12  anti-venom injections depending on the  severity of your symptoms now it's very  unlikely that a spider would lay eggs in  your ear even if it did all you'd have  to do is rinse them out you might be  asking yourself should I wear a bug net  while I sleep just in case well there's  no need spiders can sense danger through  vibrations and we produce a lot of noise  even if you sleep with your mouth open  if a spider managed to crawl in they'd  probably just cough really hard and kill  them in the process so